welcome to the 13th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour
at this point we have gained 2 359
dollars gained earned
i think we're yeah that means we're
averaging about 30 a day that's pretty
good
that's really good yeah and we were able
to um secure some guests
really excited about these guests today
i'm really excited uh so why don't we
welcome them
to the show welcome graham and jack come
on in
it's just great thank you so much i
think you're a better host than we are
if you
just need to take over now's our goal is
to come in and just
take over you have no idea how many
takes sometimes will happen at the
beginning
and just stay welcome yeah that's like
that takes us four times
to go and say that and usually jack's
like we just gotta do it we're warmed up
we've been filming all day yeah we're
warmed up and we've also been
hosting content together for 10 years so
it's uh
it's kind of like we can tell that's
just what we uh do
you could tell when i said gained we had
to roll with it there
yeah you had to just improv at that
point you know beautiful in heart
it is so welcome to the iced coffee hour
we're super excited to have you guys on
i mean we're really excited to be on i
did not know that um
you were a local creator yeah and i
think i mentioned to you when we ran it
we ran into each other on saturday this
is like a couple days ago
that's how this came to be outside of a
coffee shop
yeah which was amazing i also was in a
hat sunglasses and had a scarf around my
neck which was uncharacteristic for me
and i had no idea how first i
saw you and i was like i think i think
that's graham steven
and i was like act cool be chill and i
told
my uh fiance i was like i think i think
i know that guy and then i turned around
and you were staring at me i was like
all right i know that guy yeah because
you look familiar it's weird
i've been recognized when i wear the
like the mask and everything i'm like
how did you know
yeah there's no way but then i saw you
and i'm like looks familiar yeah yeah
yeah
it's funny there's that look um both
from like
creator to um audience member or creator
to fan and fan to creator and then
creator to creator yeah i think where
it's just like
wait a second yeah but i'm a fan of your
content like i
really like it it's good you guys are
too good now really quick we should
do a background like like some backstory
here of of who you are on your channel
sure um you tell us actually okay how
did this start
you're making some really good videos
right now and you did like it's too good
i think like the quality i think is is
is too too much too high of quality i
really
really appreciate that yeah um our
history dates back to
um 10 years ago in or about 10 years ago
in 2011 we started making youtube
content
i had just graduated college i grew up
here in los angeles
and um i played lacrosse which was a
very foreign sport to play in los
angeles i had this idea
coming out of high school and going into
college that there should be a network
for the sport like there should be
the nfl network for lacrosse and when i
graduated college
it was unlikely that that was going to
end up on television but i still wanted
to do the idea and so just took to
youtube to start making content about
lacrosse and at the same time
during that exact same you know
two-month span of us starting this
network
uh myself and a friend colin was making
content about his lacrosse team in
colorado
there was only two people making
lacrosse content on the internet and it
was
us in la and colin in colorado and so it
was like small community yeah it was a
small community so it connected very
quickly i uploaded and i think 30
minutes later i had an email yeah
so that's so cool and we were really
viewing it as like a network so we
wanted to acquire content
and um he was making like a docu-series
it was a
very good filmmaking very good
storytelling and we wanted to acquire
his series so
that's how we met um convinced him to
move out to la
for a three-month internship yeah and
then he stayed
for nine years now nine years we've been
making content together ever since we
had a
we had a really great ride with um that
company it's called the lacrosse network
we built it from 2011 to 2014 and we
ended up selling the company
uh to a new york-based uh media group
called whistle sports
um at the time they had just brought on
dude perfect as their primary partner to
go into youtube and
we then became you know we brought on
our company
uh and our goal was to build that brand
but then
also join the team and help build out
athlete
and sports content across social
platforms i gotta know how long does it
take you to make a video
the amount of work that i bet you put in
it it's mind-blowing to me
because i know like as a creator just
like
it's not that that easy people always
think you just turn on the camera and
it's like oh
dirty derp and there's like there's a
viral video it's never like that it's
really funny as a creator because like
when i first started watching your
videos i thought the same thing i was
like how long like what's the process
what's the workflow here what's the
process
yeah it's like how are you researching
what what does your like script look
like like i'm so curious about you tell
me yours i'll tell you mine
uh it varies we're actually you know in
this ever evolving process
of trying to pin down um
and balance between letting your
creativity flow but then also being
efficient and making sure
that you're getting enough videos out to
support yourself as
a company and and uh you know for us we
oscillate between some of our videos
take ten days
uh because they have interviews they
have a ton of different
pieces of b-roll they have writing
sessions rewriting sessions uh
colin you know totally leads on that
process
and he from day one since the
day i met him he's just like super
intensive on storytelling
and if the story doesn't make sense it
doesn't go out
and that means like every frame builds
on top of each other and if it doesn't
we're going to lose people's attention
we're going to
not you know create something that's
conversational at all
and so now we're starting to work into
spaces where when we started talking
about ourself like we made a video that
you commented on
called how much youtube pays us which is
kind of like a i see anything money
related i comment on that i loved it
very on brand for you um but that video
took
less time because the storytelling of it
was like personal and we were able to
tell our own story and
doing that it was it was a lot easier to
uh flip that video around so we're
trying to balance now and understand
what are the videos that are the big
swings like you know the video we made
with mr beast obviously that's a big
swing i love that video
that's gonna cross a million views uh
you know probably in the next
week or ten days and that was a big
swing that's worthy of spending a ton of
time on
now we also need the frequency of
building a community and having a
conversation with our audience
so we have to tear off our videos and
say this is a tier one video that is a
big swing
and here's a tier two video that's you
know probably in the
we're aiming for a hundred thousand
people to watch it and tier one most
likely is
it involves us interviewing someone you
look at the mr beast video there are
three different interviews
incorporated in that video each of which
were about an hour long that we recorded
so the process of going through and
sifting through it
finding which parts of that interview
you want and then putting them into a
story
and then filming our hosted that's what
really makes the process
longer trying to figure out the story
when you have so many different sources
that you're using
again like when it's just us it's much
more linear yeah why does it take 10
days but our goal now even if we have a
video that's going to take 10 days is to
make sure that we have multiple other
videos going on at the same time
that are potentially lighter lift videos
so that on 10 days go by we're not just
sitting with one youtube video
we have a couple more in the works right
i found that really interesting when you
said you have tier 1 and tier 2 videos
because something i wanted to ask you
guys
is that it's so clear like when you post
a video at least when i see it i'm like
okay this video is gonna be a banger
yeah and tons of people are gonna watch
it's gonna blow up like the david dobrik
video
like there's a reason why you guys have
done like more than one of those because
they just they blow up immediately
but at the same time i've i i feel like
you guys are there's something in you
guys that are trying to like post videos
maybe that don't
totally blow up such as like a day in
quarantine
you know like i feel like like you guys
would see that and think like
maybe this video isn't going to blow up
yeah like and you kind of know
in making it that it's not going to blow
up maybe it's a filler or you guys go
into it no it's a tier 2.
it's not necessarily a filler but i
think we've we've moved away from that
a bit uh but that comes from just the
inherent creative desire to make
other things okay and not be like in a
box
um but i would say we're very different
creators even than from that time that's
what i'm putting out
you know a day in the life video i don't
think we would ever do that and that was
two months ago three months ago yeah
yeah we've evolved quite a bit over the
past couple months
um but yeah i wouldn't even consider
that now on the chart of something that
we would consider
anymore um but yeah that
the past we've had this channel for over
three years and it's been so much
experimentation around
from when we started the channel where
you remember the days of casey neistat
daily vlogging and people just making
cool stuff about their life
we tried that we tried to tell stories
about our life
and it just wasn't interesting and we
it was just very hard for us to do and
it was really surprising because it was
like
we're very confident in our video making
ability but we couldn't find a way to
tell stories about
our life that was interesting but then
once we shifted that to the
conversations we were having about the
creator industry and just made that the
topic it like
immediately was able to find an audience
how do you know everybody
like how do you get mr beast for an
interview like that
yeah it seems like you know a lot of
people yeah it's like you are you're the
one who's interconnected
i think uh we've always i've i've
personally always prided myself on
networking
um i think somehow it just happens
coffee shops yeah
walk around the streets but also we've
used videos as networking tools
we made a video about will smith uh two
years ago
and within an hour we got an email from
his management company and then we were
able to connect with them and and work
with them we got to put will smith in
the title of this video
featuring what but yeah and that's how
was that
sometimes like that one about will smith
was sort of almost free consulting
because will smith had just joined
youtube at the time and we thought well
let's
give him our take on what he's doing on
youtube
right so his management company is going
to be on that immediately because that's
their world it's almost like
the real audience for that video even
though it hit maybe 300 000 views
was actually the five people in the will
smith management office
that's who it was directed at so they
got it immediately
even like you said like you'll see
anything about money so there was a
purpose you knew going into it that
that was your intention that was just a
better version of cold outreach in an
email okay but what about mr beast
because you had him in the video how did
that happen beast came from uh
i so we also met yes theory in that way
we made a video about them and that's
how we met them we became very close
with them
yes theory ended up doing a video with
mr beast um
we made a video about mr beast he saw it
didn't reach out to us and then uh
i had a i had one of the s theory guys
on my podcast talking about the
experience of working with mr beast
and right after he dm'd us and he was
just like hey guys
i really like your videos um can i call
you
and i gave him my number and since then
he's just been
that's fun a super close connection uh a
guy who's like
an amazing mentor i think he's a great
person to be who he is on our platform
because of who he is
yeah uh and he just has a very
vested interest in creators growing and
he's taken an interest in us and uh
that's awesome
super cool and so it's very uh it's very
cool to have someone like that to be
able to reach out to and connect with
and so that's
over time we've built a relationship to
the point where i can send him a text
and say
hey when your finger on the app game is
done can we hop on a
zoom call for a video and he's like yeah
that's awesome and that was really cool
um
and really special that is so cool yeah
congratulations i think it's just the
the quality that you put in reminds me a
bit of that that casey neistat style
yeah
100 percent of just it's it's but i
always do like i tell you like it's too
good
it's too real for youtube like this is
like movie quality stuff
yeah appreciate that yeah i appreciate
that i think a lot of that comes though
from
us having to work like so in the early
days
when we are like when we first started
the lacrosse network i i always had this
vision of working with nike i was like i
want to work with nike and so one got to
make a video about them now yeah well
when colin
when colin came in that was the goal
like that was our north star as a
as a business was we have to build
something that's
elite enough and premier enough that a
brand like nike would want to advertise
with us
and again this is such an early stage in
youtube that
it was really hard to convince anyone
that youtube was worthy so we had to
make sure that our stuff
looked like stuff that nike would want
to put their name on
and eventually nike did work with us and
when we did work with them we wanted to
use the money to level up and make
ourselves look like a tv network
uh so we always viewed youtube as just
like the democratic television channel
it wasn't like i don't think i fully
understood exactly
what it was in the beginning i just
always viewed it as that and so
working with brands working with
athletes you had to have a certain
standard of
production and filmmaking and
storytelling for them to feel excited
about
who you were otherwise they thought you
were showing up with like a flip camera
and
like saying hey we're doing a youtube
video with these guys
felt so low budget yeah we made up for
it in storytelling in filmmaking do you
ever feel like that works against you
though that you put
like 10 days of work into a video and
like all of a sudden
and and it just maybe doesn't do as well
versus you see some of these guys with
like
which guy i'm gonna and it's just like
20 minutes of zero editing
and a million views i mean we talk about
that all the time there are commentary
channels that talk about
similar topics to what we talk about and
they're just sitting down
with a lo-fi webcam basically and it'll
be a
30-minute video with a few cuts their
thoughts on us on a topic
and they'll get exponentially more views
than we did on a video where we decided
to tackle
that topic so it's definitely something
that we talk about
i i think we're really interested though
in finding that middle ground i think of
where
our brand sets apart and it is unique
and someone
can look at it and say wow that's really
dialed uh that feels like a show
but it also doesn't take as long as a tv
show would take to make yeah i'll tell
you my perspective
i liked your channel and it caught my
attention because you were making videos
like you had millions of subscribers but
i think i found you with them in like 30
or 40k
and i was like why why is it so good i
really believe and
it's like it's too good and from my
perspective too like some of these video
topics that i do we'll talk about the
stimulus briefly
i will spend like five six hours
compiling like
weeks worth of information talking about
the upcoming stimulus package
meet kevin goes on his computer for 20
minutes and just
talks for eight minutes his videos will
double my views
which is with no editing whatsoever it's
just him talking to camera and i'm
putting so much thought into this to
make it very concise
sometimes it doesn't make a difference
and so like you said there is that fine
balance
between just how much work do you want
to put in it how much risk do you want
to put in one video
potentially not doing well versus really
well
something like growing a audience online
like your goal is you're basically
aggregating a bunch of people to point
them in a certain direction
and um your ability to point them in
that direction determines the value of
you as a creator
and even if you're getting a million
people to watch you if you don't have
that ability it doesn't matter
and so i think our style our quality
like we made a video about sports about
the nfl and about cam newton that
um didn't do well but it caught the
attention of cam's
team and we were able to get a meeting
get some opportunities
get in the room with them so you start
to redefine what does it mean
to do well um same thing is like we've
talked about our networking ability has
come from our ability to make
make videos and make videos that have a
certain quality about them that it
catches the eye of people and they
have the same reaction that you have of
like there's something to these guys
that's different yes this video didn't
get a million views but
there's something about these guys that
i want to i want to engage with did you
meet david dobrik
we have met david in person but not
after that
video it was prior and um
after that though he did so the
interesting thing about that video
um why david dobrik laughed so much is
that he pumped that video as if it was a
brand deal
he did a swipe up on snapchat he did a
swipe up on instagram he commented on
the video
wow he promoted it like he was promoting
a brand deal and i've never seen a video
explode like that video yeah and it
exploded and i was telling colin i loved
that video
brandon pay would pay a lot of money for
what he just did
right for our brand uh which is really
cool and so again it's like
that the amount of effort that we put
into the videos we we've seen
uh like high returns on the investment
um but we are trying to find the balance
to make sure that we can be more
frequent because that is a part of the
youtube
algorithm yeah we got it we got a shrine
over here above the fireplace it's for
the algorithm
so before we leave we need to chant you
know smash like button smash like but
ten times good luck there's two things i
wanted to bring up one was that
we do intentionally also film in our car
because it feels very like i watched
your video
yeah and like and like it is it did
start because it was just like okay this
sounds really good in here but
i do feel like that grounds us a little
bit in our um
ability to not feel so distant in our
because our editing is very like
intricate and
it's important to feel close to your
audience
and being in that car setting feels so
relatable
now the second thing is one thing i
really love about what you do
is you're talking about such complex
topics that to me like when i'm watching
your videos there's so much value
and i think value goes way beyond
production value it's the value
to the audience is what the true value
of the video is um
and in your last video i told colin
about this this morning i loved that you
keep these easter eggs that are just so
youtube where you said
i think you said um what's up graham
it's guys yeah
and i was like that is youtube and
that's what i love about youtube
is you're just catching someone for a
moment and then
you go down to the comments and you're
like did everyone else see that and it's
like
it's just such an awesome thing that um
i think is
just not something that someone on
television who talks about money would
ever
they would be like what are you talking
about don't do that it's weird but it's
so good
and it's so relatable and it's so like
it builds that connection and again that
ability to point your audience in a
direction
because now i'm like it's to save money
yeah that's the whole direction save
money hit the like button right those
are the two
things i say in every video don't spend
money guys i think your channel though
very recently has pushed us
to try and offer more value and get more
specific
yeah in all of our videos uh if you've
been following lately like we went into
uh the specifics of an influencer
marketing deal i don't think we would
have done that
before watching your channel heavily i
just try to appeal to the biggest
audience possible which is a little bit
difficult because then you start
regurgitating the same information over
again
but uh my thing is like what could every
20 something
take away from this video that's a
little bit different from the last video
i did
and here's the thing too no one goes and
watches my old videos very rarely so i
could have said something a year ago
no one watches it because it's not new
so i i don't know about that
myself sometime really i looked up how
many views you're doing in a month and i
was
pretty impressed yeah but people are
watching your library
not really i would say probably 80
percent of the views are from the last
30 days
and then the other 20 is from previous
videos
and honestly i would say there may be 10
videos or 15 videos
out of 500 on the main channel they just
consistently get views every single
month no matter what happens
and those are usually the biggest viewed
videos everything else like
i have videos from two years ago that i
spent so much time on there's so much
value
but they'll do like 12 views a day are
they like really
topical to that time or no those are
videos that did really well at the time
it's just that curve that you know
spikes up and then it's then it dies
down and then no one goes back and
watches
all the videos interesting so i could
remake the same video every year yeah
and
it's new for those people who never go
back and see the old videos
i think what's interesting about your
channel colin and i always talk about
transformative storytelling and how
things that suggest transformation and
like that's why mr beast
does so well is because from the start
of his video to the end something
amazing happens right there's some sort
of transformation that
uh you're watching but your videos are
on the topic of money which is
arguably the most transformative thing
there is in the world like
me going from not having money to having
money or
saving money or like just an increase
talk about that and money
is the most transformational thing that
a person could go through which is what
makes your videos
so um immediate i think from a
click-through rate perspective
just like yes i'm going to click on that
it is the universal language
yes everybody that's money everybody
needs that's something i didn't realize
until i started making videos is like
this applies or can apply to
anybody yeah even if you don't think
you're into money like
you got to pay the bills it's also a
good topic for
uh i i think actually maybe you could
tell us but i think it's a good topic
for youtube because
people who talk about money there's a
lot higher cpms for them and there's a
lot more people who want to engage with
them if you're giving
advice to people about or talking yes
it's it's
hard to stay relevant in that because
interesting
mostly the principles for saving money
personal finance investing are really
basic
right only so many times they could say
the same thing i've invested in an index
fund do that consistently hold long term
build up your credit score
i could summarize everything in a 20
minute video but then you have to spice
things up right especially posting three
times a week
yeah and that's super impressive yeah
that doesn't hurt to be reminded about
as an audience member though sometimes
that's how you're just
like there's a feeling of bettering
yourself
after watching one of your videos like
taking uh
feeling a little bit more financially
secure even if you have yet to actually
take an action after watching your
videos i've noticed at least for myself
because i went through the same curve of
like for a few years you're really into
like personal finance like i would go on
reddit every single day and read like
the financial independence subreddit the
investing subreddit and be so into it
after a few years you're like oh it's
all kind of the same stuff now and you
just stop
checking it and you kind of grow through
that phase but this is something for me
i'm trying to like
throw in entertainment too so you could
keep those people engaged to
know it all but they keep coming back
because maybe there's something else or
maybe it's he'll tell a joke
maybe he'll say what's up grandma's guy
is here and like that keeps me
so like stuff like that it's yeah i
think that's the most dynamic thing is
when the personality becomes bigger than
the topic
then you can talk about anything and i
think casey did that right
casey was just like casey can still to
this day talk about anything and i'll
watch it
um and i think that's where in my
opinion when you're starting to
when you're starting to catch like onto
the algorithm in youtube and like people
are just there
willing to watch you but they're there
for a specific topic
i think the opportunity is to start to
build in things into your show like that
like
what's up graham it's guys and like
funny moments that um
happen more often than you talking about
the topic yeah so over time
basically your personality takes up more
of the time on screen than the topic
yeah and you lock in a certain group of
the audience that will be there no
matter what
i've been trying to expand i gave uh
relationship advice thanks to jack
jack set me up uh crazy story you wanna
you wanna explain this i gave
this more like marriage advice i've seen
this video yeah it was a it was a phone
call interview
where a woman was gonna divorce her
husband okay
because like i said yeah the husband
said like
and they were like we need grams yeah
the husband literally said
he was like okay so i don't want to
marry a woman who's making less than 20
of what i make in a year and then they
ended up getting married anyways
and then she started making like five
times the amount he was making
wow tables turned so she was making like
80k a month okay right so he was making
150 a year okay she was making like 20.
she was making 20 years now she's making
80 a month like a million and by the way
a lot of people felt that like that
story was fake or something okay
but completely real we can't we can't
disclose exactly what the business is
it's a very niche business i would
have no idea that this even exists to be
honest
play off-camera or you know i'll tell
you and just bleep it out yeah you
remember
okay that's really exciting
you guys couldn't hear that but what he
just said was the most unexpected thing
you could have heard
no one would guess it but yeah yeah yeah
a mill a year yeah yes wow what are we
doing we're in the wrong business
never thinking it it's just like neatly
packaged it's kind of like uh
slime right yeah like slime every like
people are making so much money
yeah so like an audience for a rational
thing
yes it is and she started making it like
crazy amount
and now all of a sudden she's wondering
if they should get a divorce
because the tables have turned because
the table so now she's saying
listen buddy you're making uh under 20
of what
yeah yeah but the plot also thickens
because there's no prenup involved
no and they got married after knowing
each other three months
three months interesting yes yeah so oh
we will get your take on this yeah
interesting sure he married her knowing
that he was making 150 170 a year she
was making 20. he did not ask for a
prenup okay uh out of good
faith he says now that she's making all
this money she was concerned that like
i'm making all this money
and he might take half of my business
and have my money and then i brought him
on the call and i said what do you think
about this wow graham what show is this
so i brought him on i said what was that
what was the thinking behind this and he
was saying well listen like
in good faith i married her knowing that
if we got divorced
i would owe her as per you know whatever
the california judge rules but
now that she's making more money she
wants me to sign a post-nuptial
agreement how is that fair
and so there's i think they already
filed for 24 so
i got in too late i could have saved
this marriage a little sooner
i would i would have recommended i think
just investing some of the money into
marriage counseling
yeah and trying to explore that and then
also i would probably recommend to
people
who are um listening out there if that's
a thought that's crossing your mind
before you get married
reevaluate it yeah you don't want to you
don't want to base your marriage like
it's uh
like based on your revenue and her
revenue i hate to interrupt
i brought that up to him and i said like
who says that he said it was it was
done in just like a joking man or a
banner but she said it wasn't
yeah she still chimed in but i said it
wasn't but he also said that he wanted
to watch this year he wanted to marry
someone it was one of the most viewed
phone calls that we got on that second
channel
can you guys clip that out and like put
it on tick tock i feel like that would
be good
it's like so interesting we'll have to
make like 10 10 parts of it
but he said he wanted to be able to
marry someone who was self-sufficient
who could at least provide for
themselves i kind of got that that like
you
you don't want someone who necessarily
relies on you for everything and at
least can
can you know pave their own way so i
kind of get that too
if he did say it as a joke the joke is
now on him
what can you do it's not a funny joke
it's not it's no that's
where you say that everyone i can't
imagine saying that at dinner with my
fiance and her laughing
yeah just being super uncomfortable yeah
such a jokester wow weird yeah but
i totally agree with you when you say
it's really important to market yourself
and maybe not like the content that
you're putting out but just you as a
person as a brand yeah and that's
exactly what we've been trying to do
with graham
right like we created a podcast so we
could talk about things that weren't so
finance related
and people could see more raw gram
because on his main channel it's heavily
like cut and stuff like that right
that's that's graham playing
a character great gram yeah
some to a certain extent i mean i know i
would say that the
the main channel the graham stefan
channel is like 95
accurate to me obviously i'm hyped up
for the camera like no one is that
energetic and you know all the time yeah
uh second channel is more
myself just exaggerated a little bit for
comedic effect the podcast is just
whatever
podcasts are awesome yeah i think you
have like a different responsibility to
each
audience on the different channels like
your main channel
actually has a pretty serious
responsibility at this point to deliver
the information like the information is
the most important part
is it correct is it easy to understand
and as you get to the gram stefan show
obviously it's like it's entertaining it
just goes downhill from there
but that was our purpose of the graham
stefan show as well because
you know we started doing reactionary
content and as well as the phone calls
where
a lot of you know on occasion we'll have
phone call people that
aren't really even about finance like
the you know the the dating or the
the marriage one and then we also had
one where a guy was gonna break up with
his girlfriend because she cost too much
money
and it was a hundred dollars a month
yeah the title was should i break up
with my girlfriend or like what was it
what do you mean
cost in the hundreds yeah because well
he would be going on dates
yeah a date with her every month one day
a month once a month yeah
and it would cost on average about a
hundred dollars in one okay
and then graham these are real by
and then that's yeah this sounds like a
dream show for me yeah
yeah this sounds like a blast i want to
have our own
yeah what i really envision for graham
on the second channel
is to have something like like mori like
you know
yeah of course
i grew up in the mori era where you
stayed home from school to watch more
yeah and jerry springer yeah
[Music]
and a girlfriend or something and and
they have financial troubles
they disagree on some i don't know their
finances or whatever and graham would
sort it out
i think it's great i mean money is one
of the biggest problems that people
relationships is hearing about it
everyone yeah no one hates hearing about
money so that's an interesting
point that we could do is like not like
marriage counseling sure yeah i'm not
qualified put it on your website
but like but financial doctors yeah
some people think that i'm qualified to
talk about this i'm not
but that's what we're trying to go i
love it it's great it's funny like
brandon graham more so as a person
rather than as like a source of news
yeah you know where you can see oh i
agree but
but i think after i started watching
your videos again i was like
i'm comfortable listening to you give me
information
and like over time it's like uh you
start to develop a relationship
with this person that you're like yeah
you could
you could like even if i'm tangentially
interested in the topic i'm like but i
enjoy listening to grammar oh
thanks so that that i think is what
we're trying to get to on our channel
where
we have to get to a point where people
are like what you you mentioned the day
in the life
video it doesn't work unless people are
just generally interested in colin and
smear and right now
we might be building towards that but
we're we're quite a ways away from
people just being like
throw me anything with these two guys in
it and i'll watch it you know and that's
it also is kind of like a cruise ship it
takes a really long time to move your
audience now we've found a format we're
gonna stick to this thing for
you know what about challenges that you
guys can do together yeah you see those
guys on
tick tock where they take a top comment
and then they do that thing
like you go to the subway the cheeky
boys yeah the chief boys yeah they're
they're man
by uh a guy out in venice so
they were just there yeah they were just
invented wow i'm telling you man venice
is campus it's a college campus of
creativity
yeah oh introduce us geez i
i don't know i think yeah i i we do
actually know
a lot of people in the creator space
which is uh which is really cool i think
also because it becomes very relatable
to have conversations with other
creators i think that's so important
so you can empathize with each other and
kind of like understand what other
people are going through everyone's the
same i've noticed yeah
it's all very did a video with pokemane
yeah that was a great video i sent it in
our um
slack to to some of the people who
helped out with our videos saying
this is what i want to graduate to like
the next time we do a video with beast i
want to be
actually on campus it was a nightmare to
do that video
but there was you said something the
amount of work
that went into that video and just the
pressure and the stress like that
morning i was just like
so nervous interesting it was hard i
also think it was because
that's not the type of content that
we're used to producing so
since it was different it required a lot
more you know what i loved about that
um you guys did like a breakdown of her
staff in that and it was so well
articulated
and that was one of yeah yeah photoshop
that was one of them
it was your idea right yeah yeah that
was jack's idea to come up with that and
then i sat in photoshop and just did
like
the jankiest you know what's crazy so
you did that yeah yourself yes
see that's one thing that i'm always
interested in is like how much of the
process
are you know creator like yourself who i
think is like
like your delivering like expert
knowledge in a certain space
i don't necessarily consider you on
first glance as like
uh a video editor or like someone who's
like proficient in photoshop but it's
interesting to hear that you're like
sitting in photo like i'm sure a large
portion of your audience is not
imagining you sitting in photoshop
making those graphics and such a unique
part of the product i actually think
something that would be really fun
um is if in certain videos you like the
animation's going on and you like pull
out of the frame and show yourself
actually creating i should be doing
because like it it'll create a really
deep connection where it's like
wait a second graham's not outsourcing
this part of the process like
humanize you yeah it would change it
would change the audience's relationship
with you to know that
when i'm watching a graphic it's graham
who made that and then you can make that
a bit like how was my graphic rated you
know have that be a conversation
have a bit like that that we're starting
to add to art that's fun yeah that's the
reason why
i never wanted like a big team or
anything like that because it's just
been me
and jack's so cool is only now recently
full time
only now so welcome jack to our podcast
ever yeah but that knows that news was
delivered in
the 12th episode correct yes that's true
yeah yeah
yeah but yeah the main channel i still
do pretty much everything myself
jack and i will deliberate over titles
and thumbnails and we'll sit there for
an
hour being like do you think this title
no because sometimes you will have an
idea for a title and a thumbnail and
you'll do it and then we'll show it to
jack
i don't like it interesting
we now are pretty strict and we won't
even make the video if we can't
title it title and same with me and
thumbnail sometimes i mean we have a
video that we're making
uh that we want to talk to you about i
mentioned it to you about education
that we've already made the thumbnail
and it's probably gonna come out in
three weeks
so like we will craft the thumbnail long
before like literally go out take a
photo
photoshop it take a look at it and be
like would people click on this or no
i found the thumbnail is always
something you do later for me it's
always a title because i will come up
with the title first and then it make
the video around
that title got it uh like one of the
ones that uh
that took me a while like i wasn't even
gonna make the video until i came up
with the title
was i finished my duplex renovation and
i was trying to think of a title because
i knew this had to be like a before and
after renovation video
and it was not gonna be big unless it
had a big title to it so i
came up with the title after hours of
thinking about it and i thought we
thought of a thumbnail
uh but that was one of those videos it
ended up doing really well just because
of the title and i crafted the entire
video around that title
yeah most videos will have to come up
with title first yeah i mean
do you look at metrics on your like on
your videos like do you track
oh wait like we don't yes okay all right
yeah we know
that if it doesn't get a certain amount
of views in the first minute right we
gotta change something so yeah
what we do our whole strategy is uh uh
first five minutes we'll just see how
the video does because sometimes
they don't send notifications in the
first like minute and it'll be
you know three minutes in fine after
five minutes if we don't see a high
enough click-through rate from the uh
the notification we know it's a title so
we'll change the title
wow if we get a big spike but then all
of a sudden it starts dropping we know
it's a thumbnail
because people clicked on the title from
the notification but now they're not
clicking through to the video afterwards
it's thumbnail so we'll play with the
thumbnail and sometimes it's both
sometimes we'll get just like just
people won't click on the video
and they don't watch the video well
that's the most stressful part because
you have a live video
it's already posted you can't do
anything to it and you have to scramble
it like you have like
maybe 30 minutes right to nail this
otherwise the video is done
and sometimes you change the thumbnail
and it works we've had a lot of oh yeah
success
and then sometimes you change the
thumbnail and title and nothing happens
yeah right
i think what's interesting we were
talking to thomas from yes there
yesterday about
the ranking system that the youtube
creator studio has
that it just why don't you explain that
yeah okay so the ranking system
basically
when you put out a new video youtube
ranks
where it stands over the amount of time
that it's been out against your other
videos that you've put out last 10
videos last 10 videos
so basically like we recently put out a
video i think right now it came out two
days ago or yesterday
yesterday and right now it's three out
of ten good and uh
what's it's a really interesting thing
because over time it shifts
based on how your videos have performed
you know five days
when your video is live for five days
it'll say in five days and 30 minutes
this has x amount of views which ranks
it number four out of your last 10
videos in five days and 30 minutes
um so it's become this very they know
what they're doing
uh but it's because you compete so much
with yourself
and like i've been so hooked we've had a
couple that have hit number one
number one number one and then you're
like number three what the hell like
just obsessed it's
jack and i yeah i have an agreement
where if we get a number one
we go get happy hour sushi seriously
that's that's our celebration
hinashi sushi nice yeah graham feels
like
physically ill if we get a 10. right
like oh yeah
yeah me too man of course if you start
you don't know
who you are as a person you're like
what's going on
i seriously believe like my channel's
done i'm just no one watches me anymore
no one cares there's no future i
literally don't have to tell them
i'm like graham it's okay like it's just
the time one video turn around though i
will tell you there is hope yeah
so like you could feel this turn around
uh i posted a tesla video like like the
tesla what is it tesla model 3
like my regrets of buying a tesla model
3 that was a 10
by far i mean that was half the views of
like the nine
right i remember that friday night i
think we went we went to
uh a mexican spot down the street and i
remember being so sad that
like my whole night was ruined i told
macy i'm like listen
heads up i'm not gonna be like seriously
you think it's a joke
creator studio told me something like
she knows if i get a 10 i tell her up
front like listen if i'm not myself
tonight it's it's not you it's it's the
ten it's the algorithm it's not good
and it just that was a night the next
day it was okay
now that video is one of the most viewed
videos on my channel it just
yeah the algorithm decided like you know
what graham we know you we had a bad
night
we're gonna make it up to you next week
yeah i did
as a frame of reference right now our
video's been out for two days and
you know x amount of hours it's number
three uh our mr beast video is number
five
on this list right now wow and that has
900 000 views right
so that kicked up like five days later
yeah the mr beast video was
disappointing when we first yeah we put
it out and we were like
ah i guess no one cares i remember
thinking like well that's that's as much
as we can possibly do
yeah that's the biggest thing on the
platform and we really went for it like
we gave
a full 14 minutes a good title he
workshopped the thumbnail with us
yeah it was a really interesting just
like wow if that doesn't work
i don't know what's going on yeah and
then it just picked up five days later
and then just went on a
rocket ship and everything was okay with
the world whoa yeah it's probably watch
time or i'm guessing
what's your retention rate on that video
the average view duration was really
good
um in the beginning i watched all the
way through i rarely watched the video
all the way through nine minutes
originally wow yeah but now it's a
little less
let me look uh now it's six minutes
not as good uh now but that's across you
know the past
seven hundred thousand views so wow um
originally it was pretty high which was
which was great
should we talk revenue do you want to
talk about stock revenue yeah okay
yeah how much money do you guys make
what's your household uh
uh what what what does dave richie say
household income
she doesn't say that what does he say
you're what is dave ramsey's
lincoln average gross income that's your
household i forget what he says
geez never mind guys ignore that joke
was that a joke
is this i was supposed to
imitate dave ramsey it didn't go over a
while uh edit that part out
yeah i think i think people were really
surprised in our how much money youtube
uh pays us video when we talked about
our expenses
um i had a couple people text me being
like yo why are you expensive so high uh
because we said uh we our expenses are
in the hundreds of thousands
um which i'm saying like our total
operating expenses like that includes
our salaries
includes our team our uh um
our new space that we have um so
you know the reality is like we're now
at a point finally
where we're able to like actually do
this full-time as
youtube creators which was not the case
over the past three years we've been
operating
as like a creative agency um we've been
uh like doing uh doing projects
for other people that don't have
anything to do with our youtube channel
there's even a point where we made
videos for a real estate company about a
building
yeah which was super interesting and um
yeah now we're doing youtube full-time
youtube like from an adsense perspective
it's
pretty small like you can see it yeah
all right let's see
um
how many people do you have working with
you so we have a full-time editor
uh named jesse shout out to jesse i know
his wife you know what is the show
editing software
jesse uses yeah of course yeah yeah we
all use premiere i mean we're all
editors you all use premiere yeah we all
use premiere
i'm trying to choose what i'm gonna like
translate here's our revenue over the
past
four weeks and then you can go to
lifetime
how how did james look at that
hold that uh always how
so do you mind if i say it or no please
okay yeah i don't care about this
one oh let's round it up 1.4 million
views 28 days
2800. that doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't make any sense
can we see the but it's our cpm what is
the cbm
our cbm is probably somewhere around
four dollars maybe five bucks
why is it so well let's let's see the
reason is but that's what i was saying
is that you talk about money and money
has a trades that are really good
but our iced coffee hour is not like
here yeah
here's the iced coffee hour literally a
hundred and thirty thousand views
a thousand dollars yeah right and what
what yeah
revenue australia hey guys from
australia watching
thank you so much you guys are trading
at over double
rcpm almost triple yeah but but even
then
that doesn't make sense i think even
double
why are you you know why i think it is
you're not putting
uh mid-roll ads in your videos blast and
minerals and we just
you are yeah okay you just started why
is your ad revenue going up
what do you see we're not bill dude
because even doubled when the monetized
playbacks are
what's their because they got about a
million yeah but they got nine times
what we have
even if we're double they should be
four times we have videos that also
trade at like a two dollar cpm
see i'll oh if i show you our cpms
you'll be really interested in um
our video called how much money youtube
pays us yeah is a
ten dollar cpm are mr beast video is a
four dollar cpm
so we range in cpms because basically
youtube's saying
how much like what type of advertiser
should go on this
when you look at your channel like i get
a lot of amazon fba
ads on your channel i love this and
you're generating
like significant revenue on um
on on those ads because they're paying a
higher premium
i don't get it i don't get it i don't
understand that you you need to be paid
way more well from our from our
beginning days on youtube
um we always said we never
ever ever will base any part of our
business
we will never attribute adsense revenue
to any part of our business like we will
never say
adsense covers our rent adsense allows
us to hire a new employee
because it's too variable so we'll never
do that i would disagree with that
because adsense i think
my theory is that that is going to be
correlated to the algorithm
i think youtube is a business obviously
and i think they're going to be
promoting content that not only makes
them look good
but is also good for advertisers so i
think if you make monetizable content
that also happens to be well
the algorithm is going to see this and
be like oh we can make a little bit more
money from this
that's how i see yeah and the algorithm
is just as variable
yes it is and so that that's what i'm
saying is that i think that
we've never we haven't seen it yet
granted we're friends with a lot of
creators who
i mean do super well on adsense and i'm
sure your main channel
is pretty significant from an adsense
perspective uh we've never experienced
it where adsense is significant it
doesn't matter if we do a couple million
views in a month it doesn't matter if
you know it's it's like again we make
some videos that do pretty well and it's
just like
not that skinny we've made more money in
adsense this month even though it's
not much than we've ever made before
more money this month than ever and
part of that i think has to do with the
fact that three out of our
last five videos have to do specifically
with money
right yeah so i think that's that's one
thing but you know we're lucky to have
a very significant brand partnership
with samsung uh
and that really changes the way that we
operate
uh we also have long-term partnerships
with storyblocks and a couple other
brands and so
that allows us to have recurring revenue
that then bases like how we're operating
as a business and let's us experiment
we've just moved into the
direct-to-consumer space with our paid
educational course
what is that so it's not sponsored yeah
it's an i'm going to plug it every time
i get but uh
it's it's a uh online storytelling
course it's about our process of coming
up with ideas and
filmmaking and um how we basically
brainstorm and craft an idea before we
turn on a camera so it's a very
extensive process an hour and a half of
content we're adding to it throughout
this year
that is selling at 100 price point it's
been out for a week and we've been able
to convert 265 people
uh to purchase that course uh in the
past week and so
for us that's a really interesting model
i think that's where we fit in more
naturally we feel like we are kind of
educators yeah we feel like we're
building a relationship with our
audience where they are willing to
pay to uh learn from us and to be a part
of our community and to workshop ideas
and
we see ourselves as being able to turn
into kind of a modern day
film school and a modern day you know
media academy
and i think that's where when i look at
our revenue like i definitely think
we'll have
uh brand partners like a samsung that's
just like we're with them they're like
our our
uh ambassador brand or we're ambassadors
for them um
but i don't see the content that we're
making being that advertise like ad
supported or advertising
i think we'll probably move into
direct-to-consumer content so you really
want to make this then
eventually about yourselves like where
you have your own audience or people
follow you for you
yeah well i think always within the
context of
uh you know our mission the mission
statement that we have
is to educate and empower the next
generation of storytellers and so for us
whenever we're talking about ourselves
is in the context of helping others
um become creators as well so like when
we talk about how much youtube pays us
the goal of that video is to educate
people on how we view creator businesses
and how
you could diversify a creator business
and how you should be looking at it if
you are an aspiring creator
um and after we made that video the
interesting thing was we had a
ton of outreach from career creators
creators with
uh millions of subscribers reaching out
about consulting and saying could you
guys
yeah maybe something i actually talked
to uh jack about earlier today yeah
so that was a really interesting
experience to be like oh okay
maybe we do view this space a little
different and maybe we do have
experiences that
um are valuable to career creators
yeah even if they don't result in the
best titles and thumbnails for the
masses
i mean to close the loop on like money
like
you know i think in total now we've made
twelve thousand dollars on youtube
adsense
okay um which is obviously not enough to
to pay our bills so yeah um our brand
deals are really what
we can't say exactly how much those pay
us but
you know again our our expenses are
in the in the hundreds of thousands of
dollars and we're able to i would say
you've got to post more
yeah that's my thing almost twice a week
maybe even three times
that's overwhelming to think about that
is but we know that that is important
we're trying to um you know rode the
company that has
all these mics is sending us podcast
gear and so we're trying to sort out
like how can we have a more frequent
uh yeah but the thing is every video has
to be a banger for you yeah it does like
you can't
throw in like a crappy episode in the
middle of the week because that'll screw
up the next video totally yeah i'm
really impressed with
your output like are you constantly
making episodes or do you have days
where you're like i'm gonna shoot three
today and then we're gonna no
almost never you shoot every day yeah
wow yeah so we got a new video posting
every single day between three channels
and it's just me and jack main channel
is just me we collaborate on titles
thumbnails
second channel jack edits so you edited
the main channel too yeah
wow yeah and i was editing the second
channel until just recently
start to finish with your first channel
how long does a video about 12 hours
a video so you got to think about 12 and
that that includes days where it's just
like you just feel like crap and you
don't feel like doing anything and
you're frustrated
and like five hours goes by and there's
nothing to talk about you're like
it's 11 a.m now i've wasted all this
time what am i doing with my life
should i take the day off no i can't
afford to do that let's keep going so
that includes
a lot of downtime like that but about 12
hours from start to like once a
hit on a topic from research planning
filming editing title thumbnail
answering comments
about 12 hours a video wow reaction
videos are easy that's
jack usually finding a video watch it
yeah that's about 40 minutes those are
also really fun to watch
um i know you did one with uh shelby
church video that i really yeah
that one did so yeah that was great that
was great because shelby's awesome so
yeah just like all in all a very cool
video yeah i like the
like the weirder videos like that like
that was a bit like living on a boat for
six hundred dollars a month like i like
those over the millennial money episodes
now at this point i like millennial
money when they were bad
right in a bad sense like people were
blown money left and right like right
really cover cover someone who's making
like 70 grand a year in los angeles
spending 80. like that's the person i
want to see right right you know
going to the clubs she's like yeah every
friday night like i know 100 bucks on
drinks
50 on food upper back that's what i like
what do you spend the most money on
uh probably food at this point and even
that well
are we not talking like housing yeah i
think just like in day to day just like
day to day
yeah uh food i would say but even that's
like like
macy and i got the cheesecake factory
the other night but what we do is we'll
get like a big
thing and then split it so that was like
30
yeah i think food and coffee is just
coffee for me is like i
love going out for coffee that's like my
number one it's not for you
no um you make it yeah wow interesting
because you don't like it
i think it's a waste of money that's
what i own it is but that's why i bring
it up because i think about it
every time i buy a coffee i'm like i
don't wow this is
like i did the calculations how do you
do it how often do you go out and get a
cup of coffee
every day how much it's expensive you go
to groundwork i'm guessing right don't
go to groundwork but i do go to uh
monadi's which is which i love when
intelligentsia was open i went to india
intelligentsia was expensive
yeah man that's all that's placed are
you working from there you just go there
when i was i would but like i that is a
part of my ritual that i'm not
really willing to compromise on and i've
just like baked that into my expenses
where i'm just like
i can't i can't not do that it's so easy
to not but i'm like
that's something i love i can't i can't
i used to go five days a week but it was
a mistake
yeah like i stopped oh yeah yeah a lot
of that though had to do with
quarantine and yeah so i think i think
it's a good thing though because
yeah i just started having cold brew at
home and now i save that money and it's
great
the only reason now i spend so much on
food and i would say at this point
maybe i don't know 100 bucks a week do
you think maybe but how much do you but
yeah
maybe maybe 80 200 a week uh just going
out to eat is because
when everything is shut down and like
you're working from home all day long
you don't really leave the house
like that is your treat to be like okay
i'll go out to dinner and we can like
you know have a meal
yeah so that that's my like totally my
my thing yeah is doing that but
otherwise like for coffee i just think
it's a waste of money
yep i don't see the experience of it
unless you're going to work there or
unless you're going to meet somebody and
it's like
a hangout spot fine uh but also i
believe for a lot of people i'm not
accusing you of anything but for a lot
of people
in this area uh no i'm kidding um no for
a lot of people
when they spend money on coffee and they
just figure you know it's what's five
bucks six dollars every now and then
usually they let that spill over into
other areas because it's never usually
just the coffee
interesting it's the coffee in the
biscuit or it's the coffee and something
else or
i went to coffee let's let's let's spend
a little money over here and you you go
in
you get one of those little food things
oh ramsay please
wow he does earthquake i didn't think
there was anything i thought there was
someone outside
i can't see rattling the door and i was
like oh my god guys what are we about to
go through together oh my god
look at this is graham doing like a
prank for us
this cat is just he's oh
hey it's fine we're gonna open it uh
this is macy
hi macy i think we i think we met yes on
saturday yeah
um so anyway so yeah back to my point
what i'm saying is this
it's same thing with with when you just
go and like you buy a new shirt it's
never just you go and buy a new shirt
it's you go and buy
a pair of pants with it you go and buy a
new car it's never just a new car
then it's like oh let me get some of the
upgrades you buy a new house it's like
let's buy new furniture
it starts with the coffee and then it's
always you know
that's usually how it is i had that
feeling when when we uh
when we first scoped out renting this
new studio like
as i was financially planning for it i
was like all right we're gonna sign a
year-long lease so i have to be prepared
for that
then additionally when you get a new
space you have to get
things in that space and additionally
when you're video creators we also
want to make the sound as good as
possible the lighting as good as
possible
um and so i think a lot of times when i
was younger i overlooked that that
okay i'm i'm renting a new space and
that's the cost is the rent every month
for the next 12 months
but you start to recognize like there
are so many costs associated
with having this new studio that you
um actually have to plan for in advance
and i think that is uh
yeah that's just something that happens
and i never thought about that with
coffee
like where if i'm going out for coffee
every day i'm like out and about
which means i'm probably more likely to
then make another purchase and
you know if i'm comfortable spending
five bucks a day what's another three
what's another
five what's another six and then it yeah
adds up that's super interesting that's
why i like the home office so much yeah
so i'll show you my studio and
after this but it's just that room right
there right and then this
that's it and in my previous place it
was the garage i just transformed the
whole garage into a studio is awesome
it just saves a lot of money doing stuff
like that yeah
well i have a question for you if uh
we can ask you a couple questions you
can ask me whatever you want right so
speaking of saving money
um we just watched your video today
about
uh you not going to college and that was
an old video yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the deep tracks
and
curious about your um position
on like what's happening with college
now uh obviously it's a very different
situation
a lot of this college is zoom based uh
but tuitions are kind of staying
similar yeah so what is your position on
or like what do you think about it i
think it's
i think it's stupid but now i'm very
biased
on college because i just i was i always
had an aversion towards school i
hated school i just didn't get the point
for me my mind works like very
practically it's like how is this going
to help me
get my end goal whatever that might be
and if this doesn't help me do that i
just don't see the point in it
uh so for me it's college seems like
it's a waste of time to waste some money
that's how i felt
and a lot of what you learn at least for
me was online it's like watching youtube
videos
like reading the internet if there's
something you want to know just google
you could google whatever you want to
know and there are people talking about
you want to network with people who are
doing exactly what you want to do
biggerpockets.com for real estate
investing there's stock market forms out
there whatever you want to do there's a
community around it online i feel like
you could learn
anything you want to through these
people but that's that's what i i think
college is a waste of money
and i think especially right now people
are realizing like wait a second i can
learn everything i need to
online um it can help in certain
industries i think if you want to be a
doctor
or a lawyer or you have an end goal
where a college degree is just
opens a door for you but i think for
most people if your goal is just i want
to make money
or i want to be my own boss and i want
to do my own thing i don't think it's
necessary jack might have a different
opinion on this though
uh yeah i think that college i've i
obviously like
plays it with a little bit higher of
like on the important scale like i think
college is
is very important for a lot of people
and i think if you don't
necessarily know what you want to do
college has like benefits and it
also and maybe it doesn't make sense but
i think that like
overall even if you're not learning
material that's necessarily applicable
in like a specific
job having a degree shows an employer
that you have some sort of discipline
and you have like maybe you're like you
have good enough work ethic and
obviously if you graduated from like a
a better college then they say oh this
guy's worked hard consistently
throughout their entire life you know
maybe they're
very reliable in the workforce i think
yeah like i think college is a fairly
important thing i mean yeah i had a
blast in college so
but i'm very intrigued now or i wasn't
that great of it i was actually i was
not a good student
i couldn't do well in the classroom but
i liked being i like the social setting
of college a lot
uh and like my ability to just like make
friends and and
network and like a lot of those people
i'm still really close with
so that was a really fun part but for me
now when i look at it i think i would
have taken a gap year
probably and reevaluated and like given
myself one year to evaluate if i should
go to college or not
which i think probably will start to
happen
more now i think you'll start to see
more people take a gap year especially
after this i want to see youtube make a
youtube academy
if you want a skill set what youtube
should do is create a whole course
like you want to be a plumber for
instance you could watch these videos at
the end of every video there's going to
be a test
the end of that is going to be like a
whole you know something you could do
maybe in person to prevent cheating
like the real estate exam like it's all
done online and then you have one state
test which is monitored
google could could seriously like pump
out their own like
graduates if they really wanted to for
coding is but like
anything i think that's something that
we'll actually see is
like the partnering of like google with
universities and scott galloway has
talked about this
uh but about like google partnering with
mit
to offer remote online certifications
yeah granted it's not gonna be for
probably like plumbing yeah um but they
can just scale their business that way
but here's what i did
i never understood too like let's say a
professor he's giving a lecture to
70 people he could do the same thing
online and 200
000 people can watch him jordan peterson
was one of the people that mentioned
this
that he just he was a professor right
and he was giving lectures
and realized that all of a sudden he
could make videos on these topics and
reach hundreds of thousands or millions
of people with his video
and it got to a certain point where he
just there wasn't enough value to give
in person because his time was
wasted instead of putting himself online
but the challenge there is that like a
lot of educators aren't
entertainers and a lot of entertainers
aren't educators uh it's i think
bridging that gap the few the select few
who
can do that well uh i think can win so
here's what i'm going to say yeah to
educate you need to entertain because
otherwise people are going to zone out i
think even the best
professors yeah yeah that's true oh yeah
yeah of course yeah you're right
do you consider have you ever thought
because you're essentially
a personal finance professor have you
ever thought about offering a course
behind a paywall
uh i do i have two oh you do yeah so we
have the youtube creator academy down
below in the description guys
and the real estate agent academy i'm
glad you asked about it
oh and we have the mentorship program
linked down below in the description
where you could talk to jack and i
twice a week jack three times a week
link down below if you're going through
a divorce
all these guys marriage counseling too
whatever you need
when did you start doing that and oh
geez that was the scariest thing i
waited until i hit 100 000 subscribers
before i monetized a single thing i was
running ads on the videos but i chose
purposely never to sell anything until i
had 100 000 because i wanted to prove
that like i wanted to do this on my own
get to 100k uh shortly after a hundred
thousand i came out with the youtube
uh no not the youtube the real estate
agent academy
and uh that was a program that would
teach people how to become a real estate
agent and grow their business
and that was the scariest thing because
i made fun of people who
sold programs on youtube like that was
my thing it's like i'm not going to be
that guy who sells programs
and i would poke fun at them and i'd
like you know call them out
and then i realized like wait a second
it's not all scammy i paint i put myself
in a corner now
where like it makes sense people are
asking for more content that just
doesn't make sense for me to put on
youtube that's too niche
i'm spending all this time doing this so
i spent six months creating this thing
and the amount of work that went into
that was a nightmare
uh it went live so i got an email list
so what i did
created an email list from mailchimp and
i said for anyone who's interested in
this
just put your email address down below i
think i got like 800 people who signed
up in like a day
and i sent out this email blast i priced
it 497 dollars and i think i offered
150 off or like something like that for
the people in the first 24 hours
guess how many sales i got out of 7-800
people
6.50 650 people yeah
no that would be a crazy high conversion
300 one
wow one person why do you think that is
do you think the price point was too
high uh price point was too high and i
didn't understand what i was doing
so the discount was not enough um the
email list
about half the people even opened the
email to begin with it was really no
urge like i made so many mistakes with
this program
that i i fixed them on the next one but
yeah even to this day the real estate
agent academy
was probably the most intensive thing
i've done in terms of information and
content
very cool but it's too niche um and
there's just not that many people want
to be a real estate agent and i just
missed the mark on marketing
and just everything that i then fixed on
the youtube creator academy
so the creator academy is the most
successful offering yeah
and how where do you sell that through
is it through your teacher oh through
that's your teachable
yeah 99 bucks a month unteachable 99
bucks a month yeah it's time yeah
wait for the students no no that's what
i do that's what you pay that's my
overhead
what's the what's the cost for the
students or like what's the price
um so it ranges 397 if there's no sales
i like to do a sale every now and then
on like a major holiday
and i'll do i think it's 200 off so
we'll get 197
on like these are usually like the black
friday sales christmas
have you ever thought about like a
membership where it's like recurring
yes that's why we have the mentorship
group down below in the description
another layout yeah that was another one
so
so that's something so that's something
too that i realized is that i was doing
these uh like the youtube creator
academy the real estate agent academy
typically what most marketers would tell
you is that you have like a low cost
like under 500
yep to get people in and then i'm
supposed to have an upsell after that
where they buy
the 397 let's just say that's the
biscuit with the coffee right yeah
and then i'm supposed to offer something
at 15 to 2 000
like some premium package and then
that's a funnel to get people to spend
20 000 spend fifty thousand
so far i've just been against that
usually i find that just to be a little
sketchy and from what i've seen a lot of
people it's just i don't feel good i
wanna offer like here's the price you
pay
it's everything you need to know there's
not gonna be like oh now to learn more i
need this yeah
so and and because i didn't have
anything else on the back end that i was
supposed to have
created the mentorship program where at
least it's it's recurring
but that's also a lot of time that goes
into that too yeah it's a community of
people
we oh that that was a zoom call i did
right before you came here when i said i
had the live stream until six
that's every thursday from five to six
pm and every sunday from
nine to ten a.m no matter what i'm
always doing this and how many people
are on those
uh it depends usually like worst case 20
most 40 wow usually it's a lot of people
yeah that's cool
that's awesome man it's a fun community
and it's just like now you become
friends with everybody because you see
them like
twice a week since the beginning of the
years when you started this up so like
you have to think
twice a week since i know seven months
ago you get to know these people and
like you start to become friends with
them very cool
and is do you see like
direct-to-consumer content offerings as
a big
path for you in the future i don't know
uh because it's a lot of time to create
something like people have
asked me to to make like a house hacking
course or like a real estate investing
course i just don't have the
energy to do it i was so burnt out from
the last one i mean yeah yeah yeah crazy
it's it's like making a movie yeah it is
it's like making a feature film
yeah it's really well for my youtube one
it's about nine hours of content oh my
god
and it's a similar format to like
my my youtube videos so imagine making
like nine hours of youtube videos
at the same time as you're making
youtube videos and planning it out and
having it be good because my biggest
fears that people buy is like this
shock the night before we went right it
was terrifying
uh i was so relieved to see somebody
yeah this was awesome i was like oh
thank god
oh yeah thank god someone thought it was
good oh yeah but you i i've always felt
like if if they buy that let's say 300
bucks yeah
you have to give 600 worth of value i
agree because
if they get what they pay for they're
going to be like because they know what
to expect but if you exceed their
expectations that's when they're like
this is really good right
so yeah i'm burnt out on that maybe at
some point i might do it but i just
physically i can't put myself mentally i
would go nuts
um what are your like maybe you've said
this on your channel but i'm just
curious what are your goals with
with youtube like we're still trying to
figure it out i don't know um
i want to not burn out it's number one i
want to keep i want to keep this going
as long as i can
and i look at people like kevin o'leary
yeah like mark cuban who have become
like these personalities
just them so i really like that but i
also want to do more than
just uh be in front of a camera all the
time like i think at some point i want
to start a business i don't know what
something something about saving money
or like credit cards or
something like that i just don't know
what it is yet financial freedom
movement what's the financial oh you
know what that is
that was jake
sorry that was a bad joke it was a very
youtube specific joke uh
anyway didn't land
my dave ramsey joke didn't land you so
we're even there sorry we're even yeah
but yeah
i i don't know i feel like a business
would be
the next vertical to go to because now
it's like
you have an audience and there's no
marketing expense on that
if i could create something that saves
people money in some way another like
it's a no-brainer
like i look at the honey app for
instance oh yeah and i'm like that saves
money
i want to make a honey app yeah and you
look at the amount of work and my other
thing is too i hate i hate being like
really stressed out so i like like my
current schedule i'm i'm it's a little
bit of stress
but it's manageable right but i like
just being laid back yeah
it's like me too man that's something
we've been talking about like we
obviously there's so many directions we
can take what we're doing right now and
there's been a lot of people who have
contacted us and want to
you know do something and uh you just
have to evaluate the lifestyle yeah
because
it's a trade-off like at the at the core
of it yes money is a currency but time
is also the
actually the most significant currency
because you can never get it back you
can always make more money
right you can't make more time yeah yeah
i think it's more important at least now
for me is
just personal fulfillment and feeling
like i'm at least doing something that
when i'm gone
like people would remember like oh they
grabbed stefan yeah i saved some money
and you know
because of his advice yeah that's what i
want yeah you know
um but it's it's doing something a
little bit more significant at some
point in the future but
right now it's like i just want to keep
going and expanding and growing i don't
feel like i'm done growing yet
yeah totally on that to move on to
something else quite yet right how are
we doing
are we missing anything we're at 1 30 on
time which is fine
how many mineral ads have played at this
point we honestly don't load these up
with ads too much
so one thing that i i really like about
your guys's content is how you do deep
dives on specific creators
and why they're so successful in their
space what would you guys say about
graham
why exactly you think he does so well in
the finance community
and if you guys could give graham gram
any advice on like how he could better
market himself or grow his channel
brand cool love that it's fun yeah i
think to start the success comes from
the value that's in each video
and you've stuck to a similar audience
each time
uh and like samir said before it's so
transformational there's nothing like
more transformational
than money and having more of it and so
i think uh that's where i would start
with with you with why it's so
successful is because there's so much
value
and it has to do with a topic that's so
transformational for so many people
i also think when it comes to the
content that you're um like when you're
when you're making a video um one thing
that we talk about is like you want
stakes to rise over time
and so when i'm watching one of your
videos i don't want to click off because
i'm there for
the long haul i'm there to hear every
bit of information that you're telling
me
and it typically culminates in the piece
of information that i was there for but
that might come
17 minutes later and because of that
your
avd is high and when your average view
duration is high you're i mean like
people are sitting there listening to
you talk potentially
looking at the screen and like looking
into your eyes and hearing you talk for
20 minutes that develops a relationship
that is
different from a lot of personal
relationships
it's pretty rare outside of the context
of us we've been sitting here for an
hour and a half talking to each other
but outside of that there's only a few
people in your life that you
listen to that's true for 20 minutes and
look into their eyes
[Music]
and that develops a very intimate
relationship with an audience
different from a channel like ours
that's like heavy editing and
you know you're getting a very edited
version of kind of
us and our storytelling you're getting a
pretty raw version of you
and i think that keeps people coming
back and then when you pair that with
the concept of the value that you're
delivering and the fact that you can
change my life
when i come to your channel if i watch
your channel over time like you said if
you save me money you've just changed my
life
so i'm actually investing time in
watching graham
and coming out on the other side a
better version of myself
it's the most transformation a sales
pitch
so i think when you look at the value
prop
of watching your channel it's all there
right um
and i think that's what's so dynamic
about why you've amassed millions of
people watching you of course
is because of all those things i think
your next frontier
is understanding that people are sitting
with you for 20 minutes
and um pushing the limits of your own
personality and your own personal
um touch into the video i think just
adding a little bit more about like like
we talked about before of like making
yourself bigger than the topic um over
time
and that's not immediate but i think
there's a world where people start to
get
um like where where you ca like these
types of podcasts and stuff
having this format is really smart
because you can have a raw version of
graham uh and then as you add in more of
your personality
into your main channel it's gonna
convert audience members over to this
channel who just want
more gram yeah because once i'm used to
having like that 20 minute dose of gram
three times a week um you're delivering
me topics about
finance about how i can save money but
over time if i'm less concerned about
you saving me money and more like i want
graham five times a week
then you're going to convert more of
those audience members over to the other
channel that's interesting uh
and so that's what i would say is going
to be the x factor of converting having
three channels that are all
like significant um at the same scale as
your main channel is when
uh your personality outgrows the topics
that was really well said geez yeah it
seems like you like recited that
yeah you planned that out i wish i could
talk like that
did you tell me relationship advice no
that is also another thing that's great
yeah
as much relationship advice yeah i think
that's the other thing because i think
money and relationships are probably the
things that that everybody will go
through at some point so yeah
and i think those are the biggest that's
why people watch jerry springer and rory
and dr phil and they love to be like
that fly on the wall be like
look how dysfunctional this is i think i
kind of want to see you
go through more experiences too as an
audience member like i love
me personally i thought the pokeman
video was so cool because i got to see
you outside of your normal environment
yeah and you were going
through an experience so i think
watching you go through an experience
like
it's why i don't know like it's why the
cooking content is fun to watch because
you're watching someone take something
from
nothing to something yeah and it's why
like some of those videos pop off on
youtube
like turning one dollar into a thousand
dollars or something like that
when you mean experiences what do you
what are you that's kind of what i mean
like new types of content like can you
can you uh
you're giving me a lot of information
yeah but can i watch you discover new
information which then allows me to
discover that new information
right so when you went into pokeman's
house i'm discovering new information
at the same pace as you discovering that
new information you're the vehicle for
me to discover new information
okay uh that is an example of an
experience
so if you could do that more with like
if you pick a topic and you're like okay
this is a topic where i could sit and
tell you this
or this is a topic where i could go
through the experience and show it to
you that's cool
okay that's where i think like if you
add that format in then i'm getting to
know you better because
naturally you know when you're
interacting with pokeman i'm getting to
know you
through that experience because i'm
watching you interact with someone else
that's well said
yep well we plan to do more like that
that's exactly one of the reasons why
we did the pokeman thing is because it
was totally out of the ordinary for
graham's type of content
and it's demographic i mean yeah yeah
totally different than
any money related thing yeah we wanted
to just introduce graham's
like finance heavy audience into a
different kind of video and see if they
liked it
and if they did then that's great
because that means that graham can do
what he wants
and he'll still get views because he's
grand totally not necessarily because
he's consistently putting up same like
informative you ever watch uh the
prophet marcus lemonis
video no that's i called it a video it's
a
television show um but anyway it's it's
basically like he goes into struggling
businesses and helps them
turn things around but it he gets into
like the nitty gritty of like their p
l sheets and like how it all works it's
a really fun video to watch all right
video again it's a really fun show to
watch
um my fiance is not interested in
business in the least
but she's grown to love marcus lemonis
and we'll watch him turn around
any business anything like gordon ramsay
with his business
or mike rowe with dirty jobs exactly
it's just like when that host becomes
bigger than the subject of the video
then it's like mythbusters
the audience gets interested in whatever
the host is doing yeah and that's like
a really interesting turning point yeah
so yeah
all right well that's that's what's next
i guess that would be a good segue that
would be a good transition into
whatever's after that yeah like if you
could if you could i think a really cool
series would be really tough to develop
and you'd have to have
people who are really interested in it
but if you came in and helped
you know creators or a person save up
for something and it was a series that
happened over time
we want to invite random people where i
could go over their finances
and just roast them like i want to be
judge judy
but then no no no first that sounds like
a second chance
roast them first and then help them but
if episode one yeah episode one is
roasting them
and then you set financial goals and
then you track those with them over time
and you get them to the point where
they're
saved enough to do something amazing
like that's going to connect me to you
times 10 right because it's like whoa i
just watched graham go through this
experience i saw his
how he interacts with people i saw him
at his you know when he's angry when
he's sad when he's like
once you get those uh human elements
added in then it's like well i'm really
connected to graham now
gotta start a daily vlog yes that's i
mean you probably could do it we can't
do that that's really hard for us
yeah it's really hard it's me sitting in
a computer you're like every day
all right guys now i'm gonna sit yeah
yeah
be interesting just to live stream that
20 like not 24 hours a day obviously but
like nine hours a day yeah i just have a
camera just always going
totally yeah what do you guys think we
could do to make the podcast better
nice coffee hour yeah this
good yeah i would recommend uh similar
to what samir's talking
about for your youtube videos but coming
up with some structure and some format
around them that make
uh the format of the show itself
almost more valuable than the episode if
that makes sense so that like
the audience has an idea of what to
expect from each show whether like
you know at this point we know we're at
the halfway point
uh and at the end we always answer this
one question from a viewer or something
like that like just having a better
understanding of
where it's going to go with some branded
moments so that as an audience member i
know where i am yeah
it could be it could be something like
you guys are mentioning how much money
the show has made
if you let the guest invest in like 10
percent of how much you've made in
something and they get to choose that'll
be fun
i don't know just like fun things and
like or like the audience save that
amount towards the end yeah we could
invest that in something like that yeah
really speculative because that's
interesting if you invest it and then
week over week you're tracking something
and like the audience can actually play
the game too they can look at how the
stock's done
you can see i think that's really fun
and if the guest can chime in
and do something with it i think that's
really interesting so like those
interactive segments where
um there's three people or there's three
groups involved in the podcast there's
the guest there's the host and there's
the audience so how does the audience
get involved in what we're doing do they
submit questions in advance uh do they
get to chime in on where the investment
goes do they get to guess how much money
every week
like what is that element of it's just
like building more ip around the show
right yeah is that even if you have the
biggest guest in the world
they still are here to fit into your
show right
yeah i've been wanting to throw in some
recurring segments exactly might have
been pretty weak like for example
every single week we do an update on um
you know how much money the podcast has
made and then i also do an
update on how my options trading has
been going because i started doing
options trading at the beginning which
is kind of investing
at the beginning of the podcast and then
i give updates every week which by the
way guys
i'm seven for seven so i haven't lost
money on the
yeah seven trades all seven trades that
i've done so
we had an idea uh every week i think it
would be fun if jack brings on a tinder
date
that's a great idea there's an idea yeah
there's an idea
or you get to pick his date for the week
or the audience i don't know something
fun like that that would be that yeah
yeah you're joking about that yeah yeah
yeah graham gets to pick your date for
the week i think i'd be interested
or graham gets or the guest gets to
respond to
you know gets to go into your tinder
have them have them
ask questions you have to ask the tinder
date that would be
super fun like awkward yeah whatever
whatever the questions are you guys have
to yeah or like you hand us your phone
and we respond we operate as jack for
the hour that we're on the show then
there's a double narrative happening
where we're
operating jack's tinder and he doesn't
know what's going on until we give him
the phone back
and then he has to be yeah
for me i would i would think it's really
funny to watch like a tinder date
meet in person yeah yeah like we're
sitting like i'm sitting here and she
just
will walk through the door and sit down
hey how's it going i'm jack nice to meet
you
but then again like one thing i thought
about this right like one thing
once graham brought it up one thing that
i i'm worried about is
when graham and i do hold on he always
does this in the most
pivotal parts yeah
oh i was saying that i'm just worried
like i think that would be a really
funny concept
um and maybe even like talk finance yeah
which is the most cringy thing to do but
i think it'd be really funny and just
weird for the viewers
but i'm so scared that you know like if
we do go out of our
normal kind of content here maybe people
will tune out because
a lot of people are like finance
diehards like they really really come
for the finance and that's it i remember
in the beginning when we first started
posting podcasts
a lot of people were saying like oh we
just want to hear more about investing
and stuff like that like that was
that was a pretty common critique of our
podcast and i'm scared if we do
stray away from from finance that maybe
people won't you know they'll tune out
like i know it's a good idea
but at the same time i have this doubt
you know yeah people really like
finance yeah they really yeah in this
business that we're all there is a
reality also that the audience is right
you're right but the audience is also
right and you have to find
a bit of a middle ground but the
audience typically wins if it's
a product right and if it's a business
um
so if you have a channel like if this
channel for you is like this is where i
get to just be myself i really enjoy
this then
it's one thing but uh if you are trying
to say hey
we want to make you know we want to make
this into a product that's
monetizable then you do have to listen
to the audience a bit and say okay let's
root it in finance like those things
that we talked about where
top of the show you announce how much
money there is you evaluate which stock
you're going to invest it in or how your
stocks are doing that you did invested
in
this one's card full there we go oh wow
oh you know what let's fix yeah
yeah so that's what i would say is like
if you rooted in finance then you can
build on top of that yeah
yeah ask the duck duck question duck
horse question
oh yeah we used to do this every podcast
would you rather fight
a hundred duck-sized horses or one
horse-sized
duck i would go 100 uh
duck size horses yeah i agree 100 ducks
everyone said we gotta find a new
question everybody how many could you
take
though i think i would just be able to
go
for a while you know like i would
recognize that that's gonna take a long
time
yeah but it's it is muscular but it's
like it's
duck sized it's a lot yeah horses maybe
i'll go duck
because i feel like i could like just
focus in on it run away get a little bit
more strategic because i only have one
enemy
yeah but horses are massive and right
right
it's a big duck all right guys well
that's it for the 13th ever episode
of the iced coffee hour thanks for
joining us our guest
is jack and what was your what was your
name again graham and graham
thanks for coming on the show uh tell
them about the two free stocks that they
could get down below in the description
right and they deposit a hundred dollars
on a weeble because one of the stocks is
worth one thousand four hundred dollars
up to check out the description to see
uh what graham just said yeah and they
could join the mentorship group you
could join the mentorship group
uh you could do all kinds of things in
the description you just hang out there
for a bit
click some links see what happens so
with that said you guys
smash the like button subscribe add us
on
instagram social platforms and
everything oh yeah just tell them to
smash like button
smash the like button smash uh the like
button yes for the youtube algorithm
yes for the youtube rhythm algorithm
algorithm yeah cool
thanks guys see you until next time
oh we got to work on a thumbnail really
quick oh yeah like a selfie or something
would you mind um clicking off is this
the first time we've had four people
this is yeah exciting all right
i'll figure out how this works there we
go cool
oh what i wanted to do is you guys
intro the iced coffee sure you guys have
a place so wait we should
graham like we're out oh we're out yeah